the death of Tony blundetto was one of
the more painful and significant in the
history of The Sopranos known as little
Tony he and Tony Soprano were cousins
and grew up together Tony B went to
prison but emerged a changed man he
intended to go straight and take up a
surprising trade I'm going to be a
licensed massage therapist for a while
he did just that when working with an
outsider started to go sour Tony B went
back to Crime the problem was that even
though he was dealt back in he didn't
Advance his quickly as he wanted he took
a contract killing job from Associates
of little Carmine shooting an associate
to Phil leotardo Tony B denied taking
the job but things escalated as Phil
Avenged that killing Phil was out for
blood but Tony Soprano was reluctant to
give Tony B up after dealing with a near
Revolt from his own men Tony took
matters into his own hands leanly
killing Tony B so that Phil wouldn't
torture him before executing him in the
season 5 episode all due respect